you know the last time I was here I
don't know if you guys know this not the
last time at the time before I taught
this one had asked at he's really
musical in fact he's so musical you're
so musical that maybe you don't know it
and the people in television land don't
know it and possibly he doesn't know it
but he picked up scat so well he can
actually translate it you know what I'm
saying when I say a scat singing the way
jazz do an example of scat singing scat
singing you know I didn't do that do you
do but you know like that yeah over
music he now actually speaks scat so he
can tell you what I'm saying when I'm
scatting I honestly don't think I know
how to says that I do I know you do I
know you do if you picked it up so well
so you're gonna scat some stuff and then
you're gonna tell them what I'm actually
singing okay okay it's a really nice day
and I'm happy to be here someone took my
stapler
yeah I'm just walking down the stairs
looking at stuff around me and I think I
saw you yo I just had a stroke that's
what it sounded like it sounded
[Applause]
you